I'm here with Art Gillespie, an engineer
and a hiring manager here at Udacity.
Thanks for coming.
>> Thanks for having me, Matt.
>> Of course.
So what I asked you here for
is that I'm trying to teach
students how to use their GitHub profile
as a portfolio to show off their work.
So I want them to get a sense
of what a hiring manager or
a recruiter actually looks for
from their GitHub profile.
>> Okay, yeah.
>> So just start out.
What is your role as a hiring manager?
>> Well, as a hiring manager, really,
it's a collaborative role where
I work with engineers on the team and
leadership,
and we sort of figure out what
attributes do we value in engineers.
We have amazing recruiters and
HR people.
We work closely with them to sort of
figure out how do we best screen for
those attributes and then of course,
I spend a lot of time
actually doing interviews.
You know screening people, looking
at people's GitHub repos, at their
LinkedIn's and what not and just trying
to get a sense of the candidates and
then making a hiring decision.
>> Cool, so
when you're looking at a GitHub profile,
what's the first thing you look at and
then why is it important.
>> Well yeah, the first thing I'd
look at is that sort of heat map of
the bottom with the activity,
the different shades
of green because that just gives me
a really good sense of does this person,
are they passionate about coding?
>> Yeah.
>> And do they contribute often?
And it doesn't have to
be like all the time but
if you see like steady patterns and
I found that that just correlates
with success in the workplace,
you know people that love to code.
>> Awesome.
And so
after your initial impressions like
you know looking at this activity chart,
so what's the next thing you look at,
like what else do you look at
to get a sense of the candidate.
>> Well for me,
the next step is just to say okay,
here are the repos they've created, here
are the repos they've contributed to,
you know where have they done the
meatiest work and pick one of those and
just dig in and I'll just spend you know
sometimes an hour just reading their
code and trying to get a sense for
the kind of engineer they are.
I also sometimes just dig into you know,
have they contributed to
other GitHub repos issues?
How do they interact with other people
in those discussions and what not.
Are they good collaborators you know?
Are they patient you know,
that sort of thing.